FRFRANÇOIS LEGAULT,
prpremier ministre du Québec
- - Tout le monde sait depuis
lolongtemps qu'il y a une électn
lele 3 octobre. Ça fait que
totous les partis politiques sot
susur un pied d'égalité.
SiSi, demain matin, on change
lala loi puis qu'on dit...
D'D'habitude, une campagne
élélectorale d dure cinq semain.
BiBien si on dit qu'il faut pas
ququ'il y ait de publicité ou,
enen tout cas, que les coûts
sosoient tenus compte dans
leles dix semaines avant, bien,
jeje vous prédis qu'il y a
dudu monde qui va faire de la
pupublicité 11 semaines avant.
C'C'est qu'un moment donné,
ouoù trace-t-on la ligne?
CeCe qui est important, puis, ç,
onon suit ça de façon religieus,
c'c'est quand il y a de
lala publicité partisane,
c'c'est payé à 100 % par le par,
dadans notre cas, par la CAQ.
FrFrançois Legault a encore été
ququestionné sur les nombreuses,
trtrès nombreuses publicités
dede la CAQ. Vous les avez
ssûrement vues.
ElElles sont partout.
PoPourtant, la campagne n'est
mmême pas encore commencée.
LaLa CAQ tire profit d'un flou
dadans la loi électorale sur
leles dépenses de précampagne.
ReRegardez les chiffres pour
leles réseaux sociaux.
D'D'avril à juillet, le parti
dede François Legault a dépensé
prpresque autant que les
ququatre autres réunis.
CeCes publicités en valent-elles
leles dépenses?
AvAvec nous, Véronique Prince,
cocorrespondante parlementaire
àà Québec, et Jean-Jacques
StStréliski, professeur associé
àà HEC Montréal et spécialiste
enen stratégie de l'image.
BoBonsoir!
VoVous avez une spécialité sur e
didiscours politique. Vous avez
fafait votre maîtrise là-dessus.
IlIl en a vu beaucoup, Jean-
JaJacques!
CoCommenter ce que M. de Legault
vivient de dire.
L'L'appel lancé il y a une dizae
dede jours par Pierre Reid ne
sesemble pas avoir été entendu.
- - Tant qu'il n'y aura pas
d'd'encadrement, les partis
popolitiques vont en profiter.
ToTous les partis politiques. En
cece sens, François Legault n'a
papas tort quand tous les partis
dede peuvent en profiter. Oui et
nonon. Oui, parce qu'une campage
d'd'élections à date fixe, ça
pepermet une certaine
prprévisibilité. Tous les partis
prprofitent de cette prévisibilé
ququi leur donne une facilité. u
niniveau du recrutement par
exexemple. Ils peuvent commencer
leleur campagne un an avant et
cocommencer à recruter des
cacandidats qui ont déjà un
ememploi, qui doivent annoncer
leleur emploi, la campagne peut
dédéclencher aux plus tard le 2.
AuAussi, ça leur permet de lancr
leleur plate-forme. Le Parti
lilibéral a lancé la sienne au
momois de juin. Éric Duhaime pat
enen campagne électorale dimanc,
unune semaine avant le temps. Ia
enenvoyé une communication pour
didire que sa campagne, il a
dédéclenché le dimanche 21 août.
EnEnsuite, ça permet aux parties
popolitiques de préparer leur
bubudget, leur cagnotte
élélectorale, de tester leur
liligne, leur message des semais
etet des mois à l'avance. Là oùl
n'n'y a pas d'égalité
cocontrairement ce que dit
FrFrançois Legault, c'est que
cecertains que le parti au pouvr
pepeut effectuer des dépenses
pupublicitaires plus importantes
dedes mois à l'avance en économ,
enen finance, en éducation. Ils
pepeuvent se bâtir un budget
prpréélectoral au mois de mars
prprécédent la campagne. C'est
clclair qu'il a un avantage sur
leles autres parce qu'il est au
popouvoir.
- - Il à tous ces avantages il a
auaussi l'avantage d'être prépaé
trtrès à l'avance. Je sais
prproportion des moyens qui sont
mimis à disposition ou de ses
pupublicité préélectorale
prprononçant, à la CAQ, une
ororganisation stratégique qui t
bebeaucoup plus importante et qi
ririsque de donner, on verra, ms
dedes résultats un peu plus
prprobants dans la mesure où on
sasait que M. Legault a aussi, l
a a les sondages pour lui. Ils e
sosont dits : on va pas échapper
lele ballon. On va y aller à tos
azazimuts. Et c'est ce qu'ils ot
fafait. On les voit partout.
- - Sur la question de l'iniquié
enentre tous les partis, qu'este
quque vous en dites?
- - L'iniquité, elle fait partiu
dodossier. C'est-à-dire, le
gogouvernement au pouvoir, c'est
lele gouvernement qui a en
l'l'occurrence véritablement de
l'l'expérience et il a
efeffectivement plus de moyens.
EsEst-ce que c'est inéquitable?
C'C'est pas à nous de le dire.
C'C'est véritablement au règlemt
ququ'on doit changer pour essayr
dede préciser le rôle de la
pupublicité en période
prpréélectorale, c'est ce qui
n'n'est pas fait pour le moment.
C'C'est ce qui permet à la CAQ
d'd'exploiter ce flou artistiqu.
EnEn cette matière, il y a
ininiquité.
- - Est-ce que c'est efficace,
cecette publicité préélectoralen
ririsque d'ennuyer les gens trop
rarapidement?
- - Dans le cas de François
LeLegault pendant les deux
dedernières années, c'était
prprincipalement des messages ls
àà la pandémie qui livrait,
c'c'était pas toujours des bonns
nonouvelles, même que la majorié
dudu temps, c'était des mauvaiss
nonouvelles. La publicité dans n
cacas, ça permet non seulement e
coconsolider des acquis, mais
pepermet aussi d'essayer de
prprotéger d'autres acquis qui
sosont plus à risque, quand on
pepense à la région de Québec ùu
leles gens commencent à être
inintéressés à entendre ce que
EÉric Duhaime dit. Les publicits
dede François Legault seront pe-
êêtre plus visibles dans la
rérégion de Québec à ce moment-.
CÇa se peut que son équipe est
ciciblée davantage certaine
rérégions comme ça. Aussi,
FrFrançois Legault, comme
n'n'importe quel chef de
gogouvernement, il doit montrer
soson côté un peu plus givré, ns
momontrer son côté plus joyeux,à
lala rencontre des gens, ce qui
n'n'a pas pu faire durant les
dedernières années pendant la
papandémie. Les publicités lui
pepermettent de montrer ce côté.
- - Il recourt également aux
réréseaux sociaux. C'est
l'l'omniprésence. Ça soutient ls
ststratégies de campagne.
- - C'est indispensable
auaujourd'hui. Les médias sociax
jojouent un rôle prépondérant.
ToTout le monde regarde pas la
tétélévision et beaucoup de gens
sosont adaptés médias sociaux.
MaMaintenant, il faut regarder
ququ'à l'intérieur, il faut
reregarder aussi ce qui va se
fafaire à l'intérieur de chaque
paparti politique. On a beaucoup
paparlé de la CAQ et de M.
LeLegault, mais il y a aussi qu,
dadans les autres camps, il y a
dedes stratégies qui sont en trn
dede se développer. On voit ça,
dedes messages, sur les médias
sosociaux justement, certains
cacandidats qui se prononcent sr
cecertaines questions important.
OnOn sent nettement, là encore,n
écécart entre la préparation dea
CACAQ et la préparation des auts
paparties.
- - On a un tableau qui implique
lala disparité des dépenses. On
pepeut le voir peut-être, le
tatableau. En même temps, est-ce
quque c'est simplement une
ququestion de moyensns? Est-ce e
leles autres parties se disent :
onon dépensera pas notre argent
llà, parce qu'en campagne, c'est
pepeut-être de l'argent gaspill?
- - Je ne le dirai pas comme ça.
CeCe que je sais, effectivement,
ilil y a la stratégie des moyen,
lala CAQ a plus les moyens, c'et
évévident. Et d'un autre côté, l
y y a véritablement la vraie
ststratégie de communication
auautrement dit celle des
cocontenus. C'est là où M. Legat
esest attendu je pense en
cacampagne. Il sera attendu dans
leles publicités mais surtout ds
leles débats. Parce qu'il y a ds
grgrandes questions qui, pour
l'l'instant, sont absentes de
totoute publicité. Si vous prenz
lala question de l'environnemen,
auaujourd'hui, il y a eu l'affae
dede la fonderie Horne, mais por
l'l'instant, il y a encore des
grgrands enjeux desquels qui n't
papas été adressés actuellemente
fafaçon préélectorale et qui dea
êêtre lettre nécessairement. Là,
leles autres candidats attenden.
- - Éric Duhaime est très préset
susur Facebook. Pour l'anecdote,
seseulement, pour montrer que ds
fofois ça déborde, on a vu la de
ââgée qui avait provoqué une
cocontroverse. Mais hier, je
chcherchais une publicité où cee
cacandidat disait... on va
l'l'écouter. La CAQ à retirer
cecette publicité.
- - Je croise M. Legault,
ilil me demande ma famille.
JeJe lui présente ma fille.
JeJe lui dis : Ah! voici
mama petite! Elle marche pas
enencore, mais ça va venir.
EtEt puis, plus tard dans
lala soirée, ma fille s'est mise
àà marcher vers François Legaul.
AlAlors, c'est à lui
dede regarder et de me dire :
"M"Mais pourtant, Justine,
vovous m'aviez dit qu'elle
mamarchait pas, cette petite!"
JeJe lui ai donc répondu :
C'C'est la magie de la CAQ.
- - Véronique?
- - C'est sûr qu'une publicité
cocomme celle-là, c'était planié
papar la CAQ. Il y a quelqu'un
dadans l'équipe publicitaire qua
didit : c'est bon, c'est extrai!
C'C'est celui-là concours. Le mt
dadans la publicité. Il savait
prprobablement que ça allait fae
réréagir. En même temps, ils ont
tetesté jusqu'où se faisait
réréagir. Ils se sont aperçus qe
çaça passait un peu moins bien.
C'C'est pas grave, on l'a retir.
OnOn n'en a d'autres, ils en ont
fafait des dizaines avec des ge.
IlIls ont les archives. Ils
pepeuvent dire : c'est celui-là
ququ'on va sortir à la place. Iy
a a d'autres possibilités. En me
tetemps, une publicité comme
cecelle-là, c'est pas
nénécessairement une publicité
nénégative. À la limite, ils vot
avavoir fait parler d'eux pendat
4848 h.
- - C'est pas mauvais, bien
enentendu. C'est un petit peu
ananecdotique.
CeCette patinage, absolument.
EsEst-ce qu'on dirait que c'estn
mimiracle que M. Legault réussie
àà faire marcher des enfants?
- - Ça peut être dangereux de
dédéborder.
- - Absolument. Ils ont bien fat
dede la retirer. Autre chose
imimportante, ils appellent ça s
vovox pop. Le fait d'appeler ça
dedes vox pop, ça permet de ne s
apappeler ça des publicités.
- - Et vous êtes un fervent
dédéfenseurs de la publicité.
- - Je crois pour certaines
gégénérations, certaines tranchs
d'd'âge, certains publics. C'est
popourquoi la CAQ investit
bebeaucoup dans les réseaux
sosociaux. On voit qu'aujourd'h,
enen 2022, il y a toutes sortese
fafaçons de faire de la publici.
LeLes partis politiques sont en
trtrain d'explorer toutes les
fafaçons pour rejoindre
didifférentes générations commee
lele disais et essayer de les
fafaire sortir pour aller voter.
C'C'est ça l'important.
- - On reviendra sur le contenue
ceces publicités. Véronique, c't
totoujours un plaisir de